gilles savary merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce matin en direct
alors nouveau nouvelle conférence de
presse ce soir du premier ministre du
ministre de la santé selon un sondage
enap 83% des français pensent qu'un
troisième confinement est inévitable ce
n'est pas le cas pas pour le moment au
prix par l'exécutif néo - est-ce que ça
va être tenable
écoutez moi je ne suis pas parmi ces ces
prédicateurs de la dernière heure qui
vous explique ce qu'il aurait fallu
faire et ce qu'il faut faire
je ne suis pas scientifique on sait que
nous sommes menacés par la mutation du
virus et que l'exécutif chemine sur une
ligne de crête
il a choisi de donner priorité à la vie
sociale et économique
parce que la situation sanitaire est à
peu près contenu là ne sais pas si ça
sera durable en tout cas il ya d'autres
solutions il ya des solutions
alternatives
probablement et je pense que le
président la république y réfléchit
alors en tout cas le président de la
république justement qui entend
accélérer la stratégie vaccinale
l'europe se dit désormais prête à à
commander des vaccins russe on se
souvient à vaccin qui a été qu'ils
avaient été moquée quand il est arrivé
de russie voyez ce qu'on a dit mardi
renaud muselier le président de la
région provence alpes côte d'azur
j'invite tout le monde à plus de
modestie souvenez quand monsieur poutine
nous a expliqué qu'il commençait à
vacciner dans son propre pays
l'ensemble du continent européen à clé
et de rire la vérité c'est que l'on doit
être plus modeste et on ne doit pas
faire de politique de santé quand on est
globalement en retard à chaque fois
alors est ce que vous vous joignez ses
propos de renaud muselier pâte politique
de santé et un peu plus de modestie
là où je le rejoins c'est que cette
klischko vite quand même nous aura mis
devant une réalité la france et l'europe
ont perdu leur capacité d'initiative
c'est pas elle qui ont découvert le
premier vaccin et les capacités de
production spécialement france ne sont
pas là donc je crois qu'il faudrait
qu'on tire la conclusion tout ça à force
de taper sur les entreprises de leur
mettre des contraintes on s'aperçoit
qu'elles sont parqués ailleurs et que
ailleurs d'ailleurs ce sont souvent des
français ou des européens qui
aujourd'hui sont à la tête des
entreprises qui nous amène le vaccin que
ce soit pour astrazeneca ou moderna je
crois
il m'en faut être modeste la deuxième
règle c'est partout il ya un vaccin
disponible et qui correspond aux normes
sanitaires européennes
il faut évidemment saisi nous sommes
aujourd'hui en état de dépendance
donc il faut l'acheter en tout cas une
crise sanitaire qui a des conséquences
économiques très importantes on en parle
tous les jours
nouvelle mobilisation aujourd'hui à
l'appel de plusieurs syndicats contre la
précarité pour plus de justice sociale
notamment et dans le même temps on l'a
vu dans ce journal les députés eux vont
bénéficier d'une hausse de leur
enveloppe de la dotation matérielle est
ce que vous comprenez que ça puisse
choquer une partie des français
oui d'accord je comprends que ça puisse
choquer une partie de france est tout
simplement parce qu'il ya dans ce pays
un antiparlementarisme l'attend nos
députés en réalité ont très peu les
moyens de faire leur travail
contrairement à ce que l'on pense et
leurs salaires ne sont pas excessifs
il ya peut-être trop de députés je suis
à peu près d'accord mais je crois qu'il
faut arrêter de se plaindre en
permanence que l'assemblée nationale est
impuissante et le faire en sorte
d'accroître en permanence son
impuissance à la désignant comme bouc
émissaire
il y à l'assemblée nationale des gens
ils sont extrêmement consciencieux
simplement un déséquilibre des
institutions je pense que il ya trop de
pouvoirs aux prêts dans la république
est trop peu à l'assemblée
et je pense qu'il faudra redonner à
l'assemblée il faudrait lui redonner les
moyens de travailler donc je n'adhère
pas à cette démagogie d'attentes qui est
d'extrême droite à l'extrême gauche
en réalité et est en train aujourd'hui
de contaminer le pays est d'affaiblir
considérablement nos institutions
monsanto aussi l'inquiétude là encore
d'une partie des français face au recul
des libertés en pleine situation
sanitaire selon une étude du groupe
britannique the economist publié hier
eh bien la france est réglé et relégué
pardon dans la catégorie des démocraties
défaillante
est ce que c'est quelque chose que vous
constatez aussi coûté ce qui est sûr
c'est que dans ceux d'une crise
exceptionnelle que ce soit une guerre où
une pandémie il y à des restrictions de
liberté la question est de savoir si ces
restrictions de liberté s'inscrivent
dans nos institutions et s'imprime de
façon définitive ou si elles sont
temporaires je ne suis pas choqué qu'un
exécutif qui à prendre des décisions
extrêmement rapide extrêmement difficile
fasse en sorte de prendre un peu plus le
pouvoir pendant cette période plutôt que
de rentrer dans des palabres
son très long imaginons qu'on fasse une
heure et c'est une loi ou un projet de
loi aujourd'hui c'est au minimum 18 mois
est-ce que l'on peut prendre des
décisions en 18 mois
face au virus non il y a donc il y a
donc un conseil de défense simplement
peut-être que le conseil de défense je
vais vendre plus de comptes à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat mais
je pense qu'il faut accepter ces
périodes où l'exécutif français
responsabilités qui seront sanctionnées
d'ailleurs éventuellement par les
prochaines élections
c'est ça la démocratie donc je n'adhère
pas complètement à tout ça et je
conseille à tous ceux qui considèrent
que la démocratie est très frustré dans
notre pays d'aller faire un tour chez
monsieur poutine ou d'aller faire un
tour dans plein de pays du monde savait
je pense que il faut quand même que l'on
garde raison et ça n'est pas parce qu'on
a besoin de gouverner dans l'urgence et
de prendre des décisions rapides et que
l'on ait une dévolution de pouvoir un
peu exceptionnel à un moment donné à
l'exécutif que la démocratie française
et et est en train de sombrer séparé
avant tout un les questions sociales au
coeur de la crise sanitaire des
questions chère à la gauche notamment au
parti socialiste
et c'est votre ancien parti regardez ce
sondage concernant les intentions de
vente dans l'hypothèse d'une unification
de la gauche
aucun des candidats ne dépasserait 16%
des intentions de vote
comment est ce que vous les expliquer le
déclin de cette gauche notamment du
parti socialiste votre ancien parti
écoutez moi je fais partie de la gauche
sociale démocrate
je n'ai jamais adhéré à l'air m mais je
soutiens le président de la république
et j'ai monté à une formation politique
que jean yves le drian vert voulu
présider pour ces raisons là je pense
que aujourd'hui la gauche est très
divergentes au point idéologique il n'y
a pas grand rapport entre les
socialistes classique
monsieur mélenchon qui est un
national-populiste libérales ou les
verts français sont réalité infiltrés
par l'extrême gauche
donc la gauche aujourd'hui les ans c'est
mon sentiment qu'elle n'a pas
aujourd'hui le le matériau pour
gouverner donc il faut que l'on
s'attelle à construire une gauche
moderne une gauche qui ne soit pas
simplement celle de la surenchère
misérabiliste la surenchère sociale mais
qui sait concilier aussi avec la
production et avec l'entreprise ça sera
des défis considérables
et du coup il faut aujourd'hui que l'on
reprenne eux comment dirais-je le
contrôle de notre économie
si notre indépendance et c'est même le
financement de notre système social qui
sont en jeu concernant la politique
intérieure dossiers examinés en ce
moment à l'assemblée la loi sur le
séparatisme les leaders religieux à
toutes les religions confondues sont
vent debout contre cette loi
à droite également regarder les propos
de françois xavier benami la vraie
menace c'est la montée de l'islamisme
la vraie réponse c'est de redire ce
qu'est la france et ce qu'elle ne
négociera jamais emmanuel macron
regrette que notre droit exige
l'assimilation à la communauté française
mais comment alors s'opposer au
séparatisme alors cette loi sur le
séparatisme ce qu'elle vise juste selon
vous je pense que elle vise au moins
pour la première fois l'ennemi déclaré
celui qui veut en réalité combattre
notre modèle de société
celui qui veut prendre le contrôle des
femmes celui qui veut prendre le
contrôle des consciences des enfants
celui qui veut en réalité s'attaquer la
démocratie à nos valeurs de liberté et
de laïcité
cette loi c'est la première qui le nomme
moi j'écoute la droite aujourd'hui il
est en surenchère
d'ailleurs elle se décale sur
l'immigration qui n'est pas tout à fait
le sujet et est donc j'observe que
jamais elle a osé faire une loi qui dit
je vais contrôler les fonds qui arrivent
dans les mosquées et dans les
associations cultuelles je vais faire en
sorte de sortir les enfants de
l'éducation par les islamistes et les
salafistes je vais faire en sorte
d'expulser des imams qui ne sont qu ils
sont pas salafistes et d'organiser le
culte musulman français
je vais faire en sorte de remettre la
laïcité au coeur du je m'aperçois que
sept mois c'est la plus courageuse ces
dernières années d'ailleurs si elles
rentrent en demande mécontents ces
cas-là ce courage voilà donc moi je la
soutiens mais cependant
cependant je pense qu'une loi n'est pas
né n'est pas en soi une solution il faut
que la république redeviennent aimable
et accueillante pour les jeunes de nos
banlieues
simplement les jeunes de nos banlieues
aussi les jeunes de notre monde rural
tous ces jeunes qui sont aujourd'hui
exclues décroché du système éducatif
je crois que si on n'a pas sur ce
républicain pour faire en sorte que l'on
soit plus proche de ces jeunes que qui
en réalité la république et ses valeurs
deviennent plus attractives que les
obscurantismes religieux et je pensais
l'islamisme en particulier politique
eh bien on échouera donc le e-mo qu'une
deuxième jambe
ces deux jeunes gens c'est de resserrer
le lien social dans les banlieues met la
place le paquet sur l'éducatif et
travailler sur des confinement
culturelle et sociale des jeunes de
notre pays qui sont décrochés que ce
soit dans les banlieues ou sur les
territoires ruraux
merci gilles savary d'avoir accepté
notre invitation dans la matinale de rtl
je le rappelle vous êtes délégué général
de territoire de progress